et pour en parler nous recevons mateo
gil alberti rédacteur en chef de putsch
médias merci matteo merci de nous avoir
rejoint ce matin alors juste une petite
rectification il ya deux cas de
contamination dans le sud de l'italie ce
sont les premiers à florence et à
palerme ça s'ajoute bien évidemment aux
autres qui se trouve au précédent qui se
trouve dans le nord
est-ce que vous avez sûrement des
nouvelles justement de là bas comment
réagit la population sur place mais la
population sur place
c'est une attitude plutôt fataliste mais
aussi d'attentes d'un sens que on voit
que les les représentants politiques du
gouvernement
essaye de mettre en place des mesures de
mise en quarantaine de contrôles en tous
cas mais en réalité on voit que sur le
terrain les choses ne se font pas mal et
ont prévu par exemple il ya eu une prise
d'assaut des supermarchés à milan sans
aucun contrôle de la part de forces de
l'ordre est donc idéal j'imagine
beaucoup de personnes surtout les plus
vulnérables les personnes âgées qui
n'ait déjà en parlant des problèmes
peut-être à se déplacer qui n'ont pas eu
la possibilité de faire des stocks
alimentaires ou en tout cas d'avoir à
tout ce qu'il fallait dans le cas où et
les été amenés à rester chez eux
une situation qui a pris de court tout
le monde ce matin le premier ministre
j'ai zappé kanté a même pointé du doigt
la gestion d'un hôpital dans le nord de
l'italie
concernant ces cas de contamination est
le problème c'est que monsieur compter
mais on oublie oublie qu il a pas voulu
son gouvernement et aussi les
gouverneurs des régions qui sont
gouvernés par des forces de centre
gauche
les mêmes qui soutiennent son
gouvernement voilà ils n'ont pas voulu
faire des quarantaines comme par exemple
a fait la france
d'ailleurs en toscane le président de la
région a même refusé de mettre en
quarantaine des personnes qui rentraient
une deux mille personnes environ qui
rentrait du nouvel an chinois
après les festivités qui rentrait de
chine parce qu'il voulait pas
stigmatiser ces populations
naturellement il fallait pas stigmatiser
cette population est le problème que
beaucoup de nos concitoyens d'origine
asiatique vivent en ce moment c'est
qu'il se sent un peu seul hymne attisé
mais désormais même les personnes qui
vient d'italie et comme ces manques à
risque d'être un peu stigmatiser mais
d'un côté c'est compréhensible parce
qu'on a peur et de l'autre côté par
contre c'est mieux d'anticiper plutôt
que d'arriver à des situations c'est une
conséquence justement si aujourd'hui on
a voilà des cas qui se multiplient en
italie c'est devenu un des trois pays
les plus touchés par l'huile il ya eu
une erreur de d'évaluation de la part du
gouvernement qui a mené de là comment
dire qui a fait de la politique alors
qu'il fallait faire faire tout
simplement de la prévention au delà des
créneaux formant des clivages politiques
moi ce que je vu dans la presse
italienne les deux dernières semaines
c'est une attitude tout simplement anti
populiste anti salvini sts surtout parce
que matteo salvini qui est actuellement
l'opposition demandé d'aidé
mesures de mise en quarantaine et on lui
répondait que c'était par exemple elle a
la charge et de la santé de la région
toscane a dit que c'était fantasy 7 2
mètres 1-1 quarantaine de personnes qui
rentraient des zones touchées
naturellement il fallait aussi
considérer les zones qu'on dira
sécondaire décontamination dans
l'essence ceux qui sont arrivés par
exemple de singapour de hong kong et
c'est le cas de la france quand il ya eu
des cas dans les alpes mais l'italie n'a
pas fait tout ça donc je steam que c'est
assez normal que la france en a mesure
pour
filtrer les arrivées de l'italie jusqu'à
cette situation italienne inquiète les
européens les pays frontaliers justement
de l'italie il normalement les ministres
de la santé européens enfin de ceux qui
sont frontaliers vont se réunir cet
après midi à rome pour mettre en place
un plan commun est-ce qu'ils vont être
capable justement de trouver une
solution à cette épidémie
je pense en tout cas pour voilà pour
essayer de s'immiscer
maintenant je pense que
la seule solution c'est à celle de
filtrer les sorties de l'italie c'est là
provoquera des dégâts économiques
importantes d'abord à l'italie et mais
aussi à l'europe parce que l'italie est
fortement connectés à la france à
l'autriche à la suisse est aussi aux
pays de l'est à travers la slovénie donc
ce n'est pas possible de faire marcher
l'économie européenne à plein régime
sans l'italie si l'italie est fortement
affaibli à cause de blocage de
l'activité chose que peut-être serra
sera nécessaire en tout cas on l'a vu
avec cette forte chute de la bourse de
milan sait aussi que la fashion week a
été un petit peu impacté et plusieurs
salons professionnels de tourisme
également annulé merci beaucoup en tout
cas mateo gil alberti d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
le rédacteur en chef de putsch mais dire
merci